se acerca el frío en europa y los
precios de la energía continúan
disparados como resultado de la invasión
rusa de ucrania para sobrellevar el
invierno la unión europea planea ciertos
cambios en el mercado eléctrico
comunitario como racionar el consumo de
energía ayuda temporal del estado
separar los precios del gas de los de la
electricidad o limitar los beneficios de
las compañías eléctricas
esto es extraordinario y redhat no está
bien generar ingresos y beneficios
extraordinarios gracias a la guerra y a
costa de los consumidores en estos
tiempos los beneficios deben compartirse
y distribuirse a los que más lo
necesitan to those directos est
von der leyen aseguró que la unión
europea está virando hacia proveedores
confiables como estados unidos noruega y
argelia mientras que a largo plazo
declaró que bruselas quiere basar su
consumo en las renovables y anunció la
creación de un nuevo banco que estimule
la inversión en hidrógeno como
alternativa verde palabras que llegan
después de que la onu criticar a la
unión por buscar nuevos combustibles
fósiles como respuesta a la restricción
de gas ruso una postura nefasta para el
clima afirmó naciones unidas la primera
dama de ucrania helenas de lens k fue
invitada de honor a la sesión vistiendo
los colores de kiev los mismos que los
de la unión von der leyen afirmó que a
pesar de las consecuencias levantar las
sanciones a rusia no está sobre la mesa
a la guancha may katy perry clear
quiero dejar claro que las sanciones
están aquí para quedarse es momento para
la determinación y sólo para la
conciliación tishman los detalles del
plan energético europeo los ultimarán el
próximo 30 de septiembre los ministros
de energía de los estados miembros de la
umh